we got more breaking news and this is
this is
best time to jump right into it pentagon
approves dc mayor's request to deploy
national guard for upcoming
demonstrations
cnn reports that acting defense
secretary christopher miller on monday
approved a request for the mayor of
washington
to deploy dc national guard forces to
the city to support local authorities
during pro-trump demonstrations
scheduled in the city this week a
defense official told cnn
mayor muriel bowser made the request
thursday in a letter addressed to major
general william j
walker the commanding general of the dc
national guard
in which she referenced protests in the
city in november and december that
resulted in large influx of participants
dc police chief robert conte told
reporters on monday the national guard
will assist with crowd management and
traffic control
freeing the city's police officers to
focus on potential acts of violence
and other security issues let me tell
you what i find particularly interesting
about this
the washington post released an op-ed by
10
former secretaries of defense defense
secretaries
all of them said involving the military
in election disputes is dangerous a lot
of people a lot of articles popped up
where they said
defense secretaries are worried trump is
going to stay jakku and things like that
or they fear that trump will use the
military for these reasons
maybe but there's something they said
that was particularly interesting
in the op-ed they said we are calling
upon christopher miller acting secretary
of defense
to uphold the peaceful transition and
they also said
any civilian or military who support
trump in using the military to subvert
this election
will face potential criminal you know uh
penalties and things of
things of that nature they're basically
saying
you better not if trump gives you the
order but they don't understand you know
uh
trump's not going to come out and order
them to just take over the country it's
not going to work that way
but they're basically i think the point
of this op-ed was to tell
trump's new acting secretary of defense
by name they said we call upon him
not to support the president here's the
thing you got to understand about chris
miller
donald trump removed the top civilian uh
leadership at the pentagon
replaced it with people who are fans of
trump
so now you've got people in the pentagon
ordering the national guard or approving
it
our trump supporters now you've got dc
tomorrow at the biggest trump supporting
event we probably will ever see
tomorrow in the 6th trump's new acting
secretary of defense saying yes
we would like the national guard to be
deployed to dc
and what happens if all these trump
supporters are on the ground and the
cops are doing something
and then they just order the national
guard to defend the right to peacefully
protest or something
is that why bowser ordered that the
national guard wouldn't be armed she was
like basically saying that what she said
yeah i think in politico i think that
might be the same one she was like i
said we know guns bowser ordered
national guard personnel no arms when
responding to protests
and they that they will not perform
surveillance searches or seizures of
protesters
this is this is really interesting
because we just had look
this op-ed from the washington post
clearly these former defense secretaries
are worried that miller
would say to the military like we're not
leaving
why would they write it unless they were
at some concerns that could happen
the fact that they said you could face
criminal penalties if you do this it was
like an open letter warning
if you lose that fight if you come out
for trump and you lose we will lock you
up right
christopher miller's not saying yes of
course the the national guard please you
know deploy them into dc
where all of our supporters will be or
is that
looking to win looking too deep into it
is miller just saying i don't know the
mayor asked for it sure fine whatever
well you gotta look at two things here
number one
if we can go back to summer uh where we
had the same problem where the mayor did
not want
national guard deployed when there was
actual civil unrest
there was real violence occurring and
assault on federal property
right and so there were even though i
know technically national guard isn't a
federal branch of the military people
say
you know if you're getting into
semantics but technically it's still
military
when federal property and the people's
house was under attack she was saying
you know this is not what we want we
don't need anything like that she wasn't
just saying that she painted
the slogan in washington dc and then
later was also attacked by the very
activists she was supposedly supporting
but
i'm saying like this is where we have to
look at what's what's ironic about this
as we switch into the new year
is that around this time i remember like
the intercept which is extremely
dishonest publication in many ways so
they do
since we're on your show i'll give them
some credence they have some some great
journalists still at work they used to
a broken clock is really twice a day but
they used to have glenn greenwald and
for that
right not so much anymore not so much
but but i remember that one of their
biggest criticisms
uh of even early on in the protest is
they were basically saying
oh elijah is you know basically such a
trick artist that he would try to
manipulate his
footage so that trump would fall for his
ploy to try to deploy
a national guard into dc like like these
publications were mocking like wait hold
on
they claimed you were trying to
selectively editing they said that trump
fell for my selectively edit
videos when he called upon them to say
that that's why we need national guard
in dc as if
me filming a live event is selective
editing however i'm just going to say
this
the media just a few months ago was
mocking journalists for
providing evidence for the national
guard being present there was evidence
for it trump was calling for it and they
were saying how dare you that's such a
stupid thing
now there's not even any evidence that
there will be mass violence there has
been no violence
yet and they're going hell yeah just put
these guys out there
because there's a trump supporters and
we've got to do what i mean prepare for
a war
well black lives matter for the past two
months dc has been putting pressure on
the mayor
putting pressure on hotels hotels have
been shut down
saying that they're housing white
supremacists that are coming to commit
violent acts not even true black people
it's not true but check this out
i find it so ridiculously interesting
that these
people are literally they're literally
the ones that are totally anti-law
enforcement
anti-police anti-everything but now
i can almost guarantee you that this
mayor called the national guard to
protect black lives matter
the mask slipped i'm sorry no no the
mask was ripped clean off
we know black lives matter is not
anti-cop because there's a video from
will from wisconsin in the milwaukee
area
where black lives matter shows up to
this guy's house and they're screaming
and flashing lights in his house
the guy pulls up a shotgun to the window
and he points it probably a bad idea but
he's defending his own home he didn't
shoot anybody
the cops go into his house and they'll
cheer and clap and yeah he's getting
arrested woo they're happy about it
i thought they wanted to to abolish or
defund the cops no i think they're just
communists
communist subverters i think they're
just subverting the constitution well
let me
let me ask you do you guys think that
the majority of
armed forces men and women support
donald trump
i would say it's a mix of people who
just want a job and people who who are
patriotic like i say honestly when i
talk to people in the armed services
this is very unpopular opinion
but when i talk to people a lot of
people that i know got into the armed
services because
they just wanted to either clean up
their life they didn't know what else to
do
and or they also like were tired of not
being respected and they wanted to do
something honorable which is a total
honorable way
and then there's this other half of
people that that i knew uh that are not
necessarily from los angeles where i
grew up
but people from like orange county let's
say more red areas
republican and they love destination of
the people who just want a job
are they not politically active then do
they not really care well
how how many how many what percentage of
the military do you think supports trump
over biden or vice versa
well it depends because when you look at
support
for from the military one of the things
that really sticks out to mind
to me and then the first thing i think
about is how ron paul was able to get
most of the u.s military servicemen to
support him during his presidential run
we saw donald trump echo some of those
similar kind of epithets and talking
points as ron paul did
so there probably is some kind of
significant base of support
but whether it's still there from his
inauguration is another question
is the leadership there that's that's my
question that's i don't mean for his
inauguration i just mean no but
does the leadership because to me what i
think is that for from my from my
understanding and really talking to
people who serve might come from a
family
of everybody's serving i'm kind of
breaking that uh that generational uh
service but
but usually you talk to soldiers you
talk to
to gruntman even talk to officers and
they usually talk about ultimately when
i'm in battle when i'm in war
there's some sort of leader above me
that i trust ultimately
that if they told me if like the
president said we're going to war and
they told me no stay in your barracks do
not leave right now
i'm staying in my barracks i'm not
leaving now i might anybody who's in the
service can correct me on this
these are just people i've spoken to
they have their allegiance to some sort
of commanding officer so what i would be
more concerned about
is not whether gruntman or whether or
whether just officers
are supporting trump but is there enough
people in command and leadership
that have the authority to command those
troops not even like really high ranking
like
medium like a couple hundred like i'm
saying they might command a couple
hundred i don't know how the ranking
filing works for all
like not generals you know i'm i'm
saying that commanders
yeah commanders and people who there
there could be
uh there's people to understand about
the you know these uh these defense
secretaries worried about trump in a
military action thing
you don't you don't need to worry about
the generals ordering the military to
support trump that's not likely
it's going to be if there's people in dc
who are mid-rank with a decent amount of
men beneath them and they just tell them
to do something
because they're defending the president
they know maybe they're defying orders
of their commanding officer
but they're like the president you know
says to do this or want something
will there be people loyal to the
president over say their immediate
commanding officer
i'm not entirely convinced that would be
the case like we talked about this
before the show
most people probably just be like i
trust my commanding officer they know
them
but the bigger issue at hand is when it
comes to the national guard to being
deployed it's coming from with the
approval of christopher miller who is
like they say a trump loyalist right
maybe that's just kind of a way to
drag him but trump did put him in
recently
what i'm telling people is you if you
are wrong if you think
these national guard dudes are going to
be ordered to stage a coup like there's
going to be some high-ranking dude who
says
we're all we're all here for trump it's
time to retake this country charge and
then we're going to seize the white
house it's never going to happen
what i'm worried about is if miller or i
don't know to what degree he can
actually order these dudes around maybe
he can't
but if some like uh officer says
hey guys can you just uh uh stand guard
around the white house while this
protest is going on
and then that is the order that is used
by trump or whatever to maintain control
or something
like people think the order is going to
be overt you're going to know what it is
a lot of these guys are going to hear
from their commanding officer hey we're
going to be guarding this bridge right
here you know there's some concerns
about potential for violence and they'll
go okay you got it because it sounds
reasonable right
then it turns out the actual reason for
guarding the bridge was to shut down
some kind of flow of traffic that would
benefit trump
long story short you don't know what the
the
those at the top really really want
they'll give you what sounds like an
innocuous order
and it could be the order that is used
to stage a coup or do something like
that you know what i mean
well that's how it's meant to be right
you just take orders and don't ask any
questions right
history dictates that too but what i'm
saying is
why would you ask questions if they said
okay we're standing guard at this bridge
right here guys there's gonna be a big
protest so uh stand guard
don't let anybody through you know only
if they're credentialed and have
security clearance or whatever
and then you get say some democrat you
know who's trying to get to congress
and the bridges shut down i'm like sorry
sir you can't come this way and they're
like i'm in congress i don't care
i got my orders nobody crosses this
bridge they don't know
it's not it's not unreasonable there's
more national guard here than there were
in kenosha let's put that into
perspective
like actual city blocks of america were
being burned down and this was like
about three nights of this and the
leadership didn't even deploy this many
national guards how many did you you
know
you know i know that they said that they
were going to activate somewhere between
like 250 and 350 and i can't i can tell
you the exact number
i probably didn't see more than 30 to 40
i saw five different vehicles at least
five vehicles um during this i might
remind you this was a time when there
was a terrorist attack on
on national soil buildings were burned
to the ground while there were children
inside
um multiple city blocks i mean i think
they said there was now three dozen
buildings that were destroyed police
evacuating
right so this was a serious uh emergency
in our in our country that was going on
and there was it's not this many
national guard deployed
and so when you have to put this into
perspective here um
they say well kenosha was a small city
well so is dc
i mean retrospectively to the actual
area it's it's like just a few city
blocks when you're talking about these
protests and where they shut down even
for the inaugural parade it's not that
large of an area
so how many people were in kenosha
riding
well that's my but that's my point
though is that the national guard was
there but they didn't do anything
meaning like you were saying about
taking the orders is my point is they
just kind of stayed by the courthouse
sure and they just stayed and guarded
this while the city burned and
that's to your point is that the
national guard is just taking orders
they're not doing luke
what they want you told me a story about
i think it was the g20 in pittsburgh
where all of you told me this story a
long time ago that you had everybody
standing in a park
and then the police were ordered to to
stand around the park
and then when people got bored they all
left and the cops were just standing
looking into an empty park for like you
know a certain amount of time
you remember that you told me a story
yep yep yep a lot of them just blindly
follow orders even when they don't
completely make sense and that that was
the time i got the crap beat out of me
pepper sprayed handcuffs
literally yeah handcuffed you just
encircled everyone nothing it was
i was there as i usually am you know or
was during these kind of events and
they just literally encircled everyone
and they started closing in and in and
they
set up a you know a perimeter closed
everyone in you try to get out they beat
the crap out of you with batons i got a
couple batons
handcuffed to everyone and then i
remember when they were pepper spraying
random people who would just talk about
their rights or saying hey this is bad
this is illegal you shouldn't be
arresting people who are just here
protesting and they just like
literally we're amazing people it's
conservatives say they're getting pepper
sprayed in their eyes and they're like
but listen it's breaking it's breaking
yeah so so i always say is like
well i'll tell you right now
unfortunately the good cops have quit
that's the scariest thing
we need the good cops to literally stop
the bad cops
but you see these videos of the cops
just being like i quit you know i can't
do this anymore
i don't want to be involved in this and
so the guys who are like i refuse to
follow this order i won't do this are
leaving
and then you're getting the equivalent
of scabs you're getting people who are
like i don't care i'll do anything for
money
and now they're coming in and now
they're going to start cracking skulls
and for a while it was really crazy
when the cops were pushing around
conservatives they'd give them the
benefit of the doubt like there's some
footage from dc
where the cops are shoving proud boys
and the proud boys are like thank you
officer thank you officer like
still not quite getting it until the
cops started defending protecting antifa
and now they're starting to be like hey
wait a minute we defended you
while they were calling to take your
budgets your pension and to take your
job
and now you're attacking us let me tell
you i told this story before
the story of occupy youngstown ohio i
love this story you know why
during the occupy movement you had all
these big protests across the country
okay youngstown ohio got interesting
because the fire department and the
police
joined in the protests now the
government of youngstown was very clever
you want to know how they how they shut
the protest down they went to the cops
and said we'll give you whatever you
want
the cops made ridiculous demands they
said you got it and then the cops turned
around and started arresting everybody
who protested with them
so the firefighters who had marched with
the cops all of a sudden the cops were
arresting them
in that amazing the moment they were
like we'll give you your paycheck they
were like
hot dog we're good arrest them everybody
we don't need them anymore there's a
quote that comes to mind that i kind of
want to read here and it says
historically the most terrible things
war genocide and slave slavery have
resulted not from disobedience but from
obedience and when you look at history
it's a very important
telling tale of people just following
orders blindly because they were told to
do so and they did
well listen it's really really simple
what's going on right now i'll laid out
for you some of these cops
may have been good people at some point
like i'm talking about the ones that are
arresting innocent people
the ones whether you're left or right
the ones that are shutting down churches
and businesses
but here's what happens we're we're
almost we're 10 months
or so nine months into a lockdown where
a third of small businesses in new
jersey
are gone permanently and this may be
across the entire country uh
the yelp is intentionally gone too i
would say now the cops
are sitting there in their car and they
see a bunch of regular americans saying
my life has been destroyed and you know
that cop thinks i don't want to lose my
job man
i'll be like them starving and begging
for food and screaming no way
you're under arrest that is i wouldn't
want to look like the people arrested in
portland
no you look you you look at these these
people who has had their restaurants
shut down
whose employees have been laid off and
there's nothing left and these protests
are turning into
regular people being like you've
destroyed my life and the cop
sees that and says i never want to be in
that position
i'll take my paycheck just tell me who
like i i
will get dropped to my knees and lick
the boot of anybody but make sure
i don't end up like them that's a coward
and a traitor you know that i've been
i've lost thousands of followers even
from trump supporters and conservatives
over the years by
literally laying this out just telling
people like listen i don't i don't back
blue that doesn't back america
and you were saying this earlier before
the show tim like the constitution is
being just thrown in the trash in
multiple big blue states it's gone
you know cops have to understand i've
been saying this a lot is police
officers
it's not enough to sit here and say well
we're just doing our job you know we're
just doing our job like you you should
have been
educated you should have known and been
aware that you took a constitutional
oath
to protect and serve the people in the
context of the constitution of the
united states of america
if you are getting orders down the pipe
that violate that and violate
civil rights in the united states of
america then we're not going to support
you
we're not going to support anything you
do at all my general understanding is
that
there's they swear an oath to the
constitution there's like the the police
oath or whatever
it's like doctors have like the
hippocratic oath whatever protect life
their community
yeah and the constitution of the united
states they're oath breakers
they are people who care not for honor
no integrity no honor
no rights of individuals it's just i
want what i deserve i get what i want
period but here's i think it's
intentional because there's two parts of
this number one
okay when i was in seattle i have i tend
to to try to get a lot of good contacts
and major police departments
obviously if you're going to be working
behind lines even incognito sometimes
you've got to make sure you're not going
to fall victim
to some of the the the intense so do you
notify police departments before going
undercover
at times yes or contacts there even this
last time i was in dc i
noted some mpd even when i was in
portland they tried to arrest me and i
had told them who i was and they let me
go
meaning they're they're there are some
very good officers who are just trying
to uphold the law
but what i did know is by talking to
different officers when did you notice
let's say this is specifically seattle
when did you notice things going
downhill
and i started asking this back in
january when i got a concussion
um and the police did nothing when the
person assaulted me in front of them
it's a common story but
people hear all the time but the police
did nothing so i was like when did this
happen the police
don't arrest someone who uh you know
assault someone in front of them
and he goes well what happened is number
one you know bad uh
bad distribution of power where
bureaucrats have too much power that are
not directly connected to the police
department this includes cities like
portland where the police chief is like
appointed by the mayor and the mayor
shares power over the police department
and he's thinking about weird leftist uh
radical leftist policies in a city not
how do we uphold law and order but on
top of that he goes that pushes a lot of
the cops who just want to uphold law
order out
so it creates this vacancy of like i
think last time i was in seattle they
had like 370 might have been
higher than that spots that were vacant
that hadn't been filled and these are
high-paying jobs like
like 60 to 80 grand which is good for
people in general
now they said so what happens is that a
lot of people now are leaving the
military
and so as they leave in the military
they're like well what do i do next now
they can go to college or a quick way
they don't have to go to colleges become
a cop and the vacancies are open where
in these big cities and a lot of
ex-military are coming in
without training with civilian training
or working with these people and they're
beginning
to come in with military training and so
the exact opposite effect is happening
where they tried to keep out the extreme
people but now the the
police academies are accepting basically
just soldiers and the police are
becoming more like a military
than like a civilian force yeah but sure
but even a soldier swears enough to
uphold the constitution yeah
but it's so much different they're
training in the military not that it it
disqualifies them i'm just saying
when you get a department of a couple
hundred guys that are all just trained
in the military
and it's not first that they're being
introduced to combat through this police
training
it's gonna be a whole different way of
enforcing things and and every officer
has told me you could see the difference
the left has been saying that for a long
time but people like matt taibi and
glenn greenwald specifically
who are some of the few uh leftists with
you know honor and that will call out
the censorship will call out the lies
and the smears from
you know intelligence agencies going
after the president and these are
liberal these are liberal dudes
soldiers i mean are thought to see
threats and eliminate them
police officers are supposed to quote
protect and serve that's the slogan here
what you were talking about reminds me
of this kind of meme going around right
now about how
allegedly stalin was teaching his
counselors how to rule and the story
goes that stalin
took took a chicken traumatized it rips
its feathers out
threw it naked on the floor and then
started throwing it throwing the chicken
pebbles
and walking away the chicken followed
him and allegedly stalin said quote
um you could do anything you want to the
people so long as they believe you are
the source of their survival
yes so when you were talking about that
specific story that's something you're
selling them food or
pebbles uh yeah no no this isn't a this
isn't a metaphor so this really happens
yeah yeah well this is the story going
around now allegedly
i haven't been able to verify it or fact
check it but this is how
stalin was teaching his counselors
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you